bonsoir antoine vladimir poutine s'est
exprimé de nouveau aujourd'hui à
l'occasion d'une réunion du conseil de
sécurité
oui en s'appuyant sur les
recommandations des experts vladimir
poutine a fait savoir que les mesures
d'auto isolement de la population sont
les plus à même de réduire les risques
de propagation du coronavirus son porte
parole a ajouté que tant que la menace
de propagation du virus persiste et donc
le risque d'une augmentation des cas
d'infection alors la période chômée qui
court pour le moment jusque fin avril
est susceptible d'être étendue comme il
l'a déjà évoqué la veille le président
russe a rappelé le rôle important des
gouverneurs de régions dans la
stabilisation de l'économie à l'échelle
locale mais bien entendu est avant tout
dans la lutte contre cette pandémie
kovy 19 qui d'après les chiffres de ce
vendredi touche 4000 149 personnes en
russie pour 34 morts à moscou dans la
foulée de l'intervention télévisée de
vladimir poutine de jeudi le maire a
annoncé que les mesures de confinement
était au moins prolongé jusqu'au 1er mai
cela fait une semaine que la capitale
est complètement confiner la mairie
estime que le régime d'auto isolement
est globalement bien respectée elle n'a
donc pas estimé nécessaire pour le
moment la mise en place d'un contrôle
plus strictes sous la forme d'un système
de laisser passer ou d'attestation comme
c'est le cas actuellement en france
merci beaucoup antoine pour toutes ces
précisions antoine gayraud en direct de
moscou